we don't hug that much no I don't really
hug anyone yeah is your family not very
touchy no we barely uh talked not a big
talker no no we talked but we don't like
converse you know what I mean it's
always like I start talking about
parents and then it's like thirty
seconds in we're both trying to find a
way out of the conversation let me ask
you did you ever kiss your dad on the
lips
you know for probably way too long I
don't mean not the duration of the kid
no it was standard dad cos 40 seconds
under this but in the rain music
swelling yeah I understand the dad kiss
but I think I was maybe like 14 until we
were still kissing on the lips I think I
was like in my mid-20s I've never told
anyone max you're really kissing your
dad on the lip yeah you know why older
brother he was doing it he was leading
the dad kiss charge once he stopped I
was like yeah this was [ __ ] up and
then you moved away he's still back at
home kissing your dad in the hips every
day a standard 40 second yeah like a
necklace the dad gets so how are you in
general you see all right I like how's
the show you will be watching it uh yeah
it's the first episode Daleks have only
seen about 40 percent of one episode
maybe 60 man I was in the bathroom for a
while how am i doing is it going okay
haha compared to it's the first episode
that's you you know who'd have a better
answer
Oh George Clooney who should have been
the first get why am i the first guest
he asked me to do it and that was like
why you know all of America can see this
they're watching it going it's a guy we
don't know interviewing the guy from Big
Bang Theory oh wait no that's also a guy
we don't know
also guy we don't because we started
together we've been friends for a very
long time 12 years 12 years yeah crazy
we're like two old guys yeah you know
you said how old you were on stage I
still feel weird saying how old how old
are you huh
will this get cut out I would say yeah a
problem of probably too old to kiss your
dad on the lips yes but not your mom
that's a very political answer yeah
that's a good job yeah yeah yeah older
than I am very slightly
now you forced my hand I'm 35 I'm just
slightly older it's all there you are
yeah slightly older I think you look
great you're very cute you're
off-putting leafit I don't I don't know
you've seen the people walking around LA
they're off-putting leafit I only go to
like pancake houses I go to pancake
houses and outdoor fairs anything where
fried dough makes an appearance I'm like
doing better than I thought feeling good
I was at you know my wife Emily
religious right I was gonna say of ours
good boy or wife my wife we went to
North Carolina State Fair yeah they were
all super excited like when you were
going to park everybody was like the new
thing that they had they'd invented
fried butter it's fried butter just a
stick of butter yep butters you
shouldn't be the focus of any dish they
took it and they they fried it right and
they were so excited they were like the
trick is it has to be frozen butter and
he just got it like fry it real quick
she's just gonna fry it and then the
people just eating these like logs like
was the stand just called I give up it's
just called the South okay blow this out
that's gonna get cut out right nope no